yeah for the Muslims yeah yeah
no foreign
to become a Muslim
that's what it means okay
there's no compulsion in Islam but that
guy is Extreme they forget him okay
you want to bring the Catholics
he said
he said the punishment in the Islamic
law will be applied to you we are part
of that under this
yeah because he was a Muslim yeah it is
but someone who is a Muslim he's already
accepted Allah
so they refuse if they refuse anymore
they don't want to carry on yeah like
the Bible if you don't want to carry you
want to be killed where does he say that
go to the Old Testament
let's go to Genesis
yeah
again because if you someone tell you to
come worship the god other than your god
of your forefather he says it's going to
death
okay
I think it's early before 18.
you know the prophet
he says anyone that comes to you anyway
and says you let us worship yes
you need to prepare him to death no he
said don't eat the
frogs of their Prophet or their dream or
that dream no no no no that one not that
one not that one not that one
is writing what he said when he said if
you leave Islam
okay
you should be put today yes
[Music]
do you know what that proves okay
okay let's assume that you believe
that yeah
so under the law in this country
but if if any Emir if Muslims ever rule
in this country and one of your brothers
leaves Islam then must be protected if
the government's here yeah the ruled by
the Islamic country
therefore they are what Muslims yeah if
the government are Muslims and these 10
Muslim countries yeah they have to
follow Constitution to implement the law
of God likewise in this country become a
Jewish
foreign
yeah can you remember the classic
where's Josh Josh good guy
it's evil for believing that okay
[Laughter]
anyway if the juice
so in Israel are they killing a past
station is that you then the following
constitutions
all right
Christianity
by the Old Testament anymore yeah
because for the New Testament yeah okay
one second
[Music]
if your very own brother yes or your own
son yes or your daughter yes or the wife
you love the wife you love yeah yes or
your close friends yes secretly entice
you yes say you let us go and worship
other gods like yes yes before you say
that like anyone like you you look you
were there or far from one end of land
yes what is it good people around you
all the people which are all around you
near or far off from you from one end of
the Earth to the other you shall not
consent to him or listen to him yes Lord
shall your eye yes
spare him or conceal him but you shall
surely kill him kill himself
because listen to the words here yes and
you shall Stone him with stones until he
died listen because he's sought to
entice you away from the Lord your God
that's not underpostage
ladies and gentlemen in the Bible
teaches you that if your brother even
your wife and your love last video I can
probably read it I want to enjoy the
reading yes yes the word of God is good
I know that Pastor it's your brother no
no there's no prophets
for anyone okay right okay let's say if
you're a brother
or the Sun or your mother or your son or
your daughter or the wife of your bosom
yeah and your friend the who is your own
soul secretly entice you say let us go
what worship other God that's purposes
in Islam because while you become posted
by worship other God yeah so listen what
should what should we do to him oh God
yes which we have not known neither you
nor your fathers of the Gods of the
people which are all around you near to
you go far oh far or from you from one
hand to the Earth to the other end of
the Earth you should not consent him or
listen to him Brothers I'm going to show
you a very important Point here
islamically what anyone can do killer
prostate it's for the government but
here anyone can do it that's with it no
show your eyes pity him you have no pity
on him no muslimited someone wait we are
telling you wait no no let me finish
islamically posted we don't kill him
straight away we take him to court
advise him try to speak to him you
didn't know that you do so you have to
you have Beats toward him okay advise
him speak to him and give him time too
you understand let us see the good of
the Bible
hurry up and finish
you spare him or console him but you
should surely kill him this advice to
whom to any people so the Jewish people
here they're not following God's
teaching to kill the prostate Jewish
because God said to do it I'm a
Christian I'm a Christian
question
right or wrong
take care of yourself